we are getting more reaction to the
death of NFL Hall of Famer Hollywood
actor and civil rights Champion Jim
Brown
the 87 year old died peacefully in his
Los Angeles home Thursday night
according to his wife
NFL commissioner Roger Goodell called
Brown a cultural figure who helped
promote change
CBS sports's James Brown takes a look
back at his life and Legacy
James Nathaniel Brown better known as
Jim was born in Saint Simon's Georgia in
1936 the son of a boxer and a
housekeeper
Brown went on to attend Syracuse
University where he was a multi-sport
Phenom
he lettered in football basketball track
and Lacrosse in which he was named first
team All-America as a senior but it was
in football that brown stood out as a
senior he ran for 986 yards in just
eight games he capped his college career
in a Cotton Bowl loss to TCU in which he
totaled 132 yards rushing and three
touchdowns and kicked three extra points
he was drafted sixth overall in the 1957
NFL Draft by the Cleveland Browns and
put together one of the most legendary
careers in NFL history
in just nine Seasons he led the NFL in
rushing eight times while also carrying
the Browns to the 1964 NFL Championship
the franchise hasn't won a title since
when Brown walked away from the game in
1965 he held the League records for most
rushes yards and touchdowns marks that
stood for more than a decade after his
exit
Brown walked off the field and into
Hollywood retiring while on the set of
the dirty dozens after much deliberation
I've come to the conclusion that I will
retired from professional football this
season
my original intention was to try and
participate in the 1966 National
Football League season
but due to circumstances this is
impossible thus began an acting career
with more than 50 credits Brown was
outspoken on civil rights and race and
became a leader in the effort to end the
inner city gang violence
while trying to dedicate his life to
keeping young black men out of prison
Brown was often in trouble with the law
himself he was arrested numerous times
on charges of violence against women
from the late 1960s to the late 1990s
Jim Brown will be remembered as a
complicated man who lived as full of
life as any who ever stepped into the
NFL field
from Syracuse to Cleveland and Hollywood
Jim Brown became a towering American
figure
sports figures and other luminaries are
reacting to Jim Brown's death this
morning Emmett Smith the NFL's all-time
leading rusher wrote quote he is and was
a true legend in sports and in the
community using his platform to help
others and former president Barack Obama
posted I was too young to remember Jim
Brown's playing days but I knew his
legacy one of the greatest football
players ever he was also an actor and
activist speaking out on civil rights
and pushing other black athletes
to do the same and remember he retired
football career-wise after just nine
Seasons after his last season was his
best one most rushing yards so could
have easily continued but said no I'm
done after a little bit of a dispute
with the owner and left before
the super Bowl became you know was
ushered into the into the into the
playing day so miss that opportunity all
together in his greatness though even
away from the game and the Legacy that
continued on through athletes LeBron
James there's this great video and
moment that people may remember where
LeBron on the court just had a bow down
to him
um you know athletes of today knowing
what he did away from the game and the
voice that he used in civil rights and
in trying to remind athletes that they
could use their voice was so important
as JB pointed out a complicated figure
a Monumental one yeah there is no doubt